pedro castillo y keiko fujimori agua y
aceite él es líder de izquierda y ella
de derecha por lo que las posturas de
los ciudadanos están muy divididas no
vamos a perder estas libertades no vamos
a tener a un dictador teniendo que
pelear por la democracia no queremos ser
un venezuela no queremos ser un cubano
queremos ser un nicaragua
queremos manifestar nuestras libertades
de efecto los simpatizantes de keiko han
vinculado castillo con el grupo
terrorista sendero luminoso en más de
una ocasión además dicen que sus planes
de gobierno amenazan a las empresas
transnacionales y organismos
constitucionales de hecho parte de sus
ofrecimientos son estatizar el país y
redactar una nueva constitución por otro
lado el antifujimorismo ha cogido mucha
fuerza en estas elecciones es una
organización criminal con gobernó con su
padre dijo algo cuando su padre se iba a
esterilizar a las mujeres del campo en
contra de su voluntad no fue cómplice y
no solamente eso quiere tomar el poder
porque sabe lo que le viene detrás del
crepe de la carne
delito gravísimo que ha cometido los
peruanos están cansados de ser
gobernados por corruptos y keiko ha
estado involucrada en el caso la valla
pto por eso se adentran en el tema de
las elecciones ante el futuro que se les
avecina ha aumentado el interés de los
peruanos en la campaña electoral
respecto a lo que vimos en la primera
vuelta que era un elector desconectado
totalmente de la elección ahora si vemos
mayor preocupación mayor seguimiento en
la campaña ante los extremos que
presentan los candidatos al balotaje por
la presidencia de perú firmaron un
acuerdo para respetar el orden
constitucional del país sin embargo hay
dudas de que cumplan su promesa